Dutch pronunciation is followed fear I'm
an actual event here so I'm happy to
tell you something about what we are
doing at UCSF and it's a large
consortium working on molecular and
clinical data actually in the real time
breast cancer world and how we are
moving all the molecular data and
computational work we're doing into the
patient care arena so just like a very
brief introduction the biological types
of breast cancer of course help us to
tailor treatments and we're particularly
interested for those breast cancer
patient that have a high risk of
recurrence may be related to the first
speaker I think the more you can zoom in
to very specific types of a cancer type
the better I think all of your
signatures will perform because not
everything is the same so breast cancer
originates in the epithelium of the
terminal ducts of the lower unit as you
can see here and is of course an
interplay between genetic makeup of the
host physical tension micro environment
and other exposures so each of those
cancers come with a different risk
factor profile and therefore also have a
different biological makeup of the tumor
itself for many many years diagnostics
in the clinic have been done by just
single gene immunise to chemistry but of
course it doesn't appreciate the full
picture of a tumor and now it all our
genomics efforts are much better to dive
into the deep it all originated from
work at Stanford from Chuck Peru and
Theresa surly by looking into the first
gene expression microarrays to
understand that if you take a section of
a tumor and in this case tumor plus
microenvironments because I think both
are very relevant to foretell the nature
of that tumor that you can in a gene
expression distinguish all the different
gene expression modules and they'd let
them to propose based on the biology
five different subtypes which are often
used and got a little bit more in other
research up to like 10 subtypes but this
is sort of the basic that is being still
being used I work myself on a prognostic
signature which he developed to really
look into the signature that could
foretell outcome of disease of a breast
cancer patients and came up with 70
genes that can foretell high risk or low
risk of developing a metastasis which is
currently used in the clinic and FDA
cleared so here what I want to tell you
about those women that are high risk of
recurrence and to see how can we
actually optimize their treatment
because if they have a high risk we
should target their treatment so many of
you are probably aware of this
particular diagram first postulated by
Weinberg and Hannah hen which is
actually often and often shown that the
biological processes in cancer are
deregulating and changing replicative
immortality tour promoting inflammation
and so there are over a thousand
targeted drugs in development and maybe
less than 50 been approved for certain
indications to actually help targets
cancer and it's it's a way of how do we
efficiently combine these therapeutics
to efficiently kill the tumor cells
there's of course genomics very helpful
so in case of high-risk breast cancer
what is studied at the moment is
targeting the tumor immune environment
for many many years people have been
looking at immune environment but only
most recently understanding what are the
relevant targets to hit with which the
ones down here the pd-1 PDL one receptor
and and likened is the most effective at
the moment but there are others that
actually target particular types of
cells in the micro environment of a
tumor tissue Mick is one of the genes
stem cells certain pa3 kinase pathways
and her two families and their many more
so we need to come up with a system to
efficiently in patients actually test
all these drugs because it had been
calculated if you
all possible if you take a thousand
targeted drugs under development and if
you if you envision that it's a
combination of two that will be most
optimal and we need to have and you have
to run a trial of a thousand patients
for each then you would need five
billion patients to actually test all
those drugs in clinical trials so it's
not in those thousand patients are
needed if you take a five year or ten
year outcome so that would take much
much too long so we need to move to
inpatient response monitoring and also
in a much shorter time frame so that
within a few months you actually know
whether there is a response or not that
also comes with a risk because you're
not really immediately evaluating
long-term outcome but I think if you
want to get to this combination of drugs
we need to come up with clever endpoints
which also includes actually imaging
people do it in different ways so it's
actually still unclear so currently the
drug start are targeting this pd-1 PDL
one receptor ligands are actually given
to all patients in melanoma or all
patients in non cancer or all in breast
cancer and people are NC responses not
in everybody and so they are developing
the test to look into whether the T cell
repertoire is actually a biomarker that
can help facilitate that indication but
it's sort of moving on in parallel it's
all in clinical trials and I think the
ice by to trial that I want to discuss
we actually set up five years ago so
that we while drug is being tested we
qualify biomarkers at the same time
under a high stringency because besides
these five billion patients didn't need
to be in clinical trials if you would
have a long-term outcome perspective you
also need to set up a system where your
stringent see in testing your genomics
is at high
d level so then you can actually meet
also at the same time tests the T cell
repertoire or other molecules in that
context so this is a trial that
originated from UCSF loresmen who is the
surgeon and don't bury who's at MD
Anderson and who runs many Beijing
probability clinical trial schemes and
one is an adaptive clinical trial so
I'll show you how we are trying to
during the trial already try to enrich
the patient population for a particular
arm that seems to respond so if you may
have you may know about her to positive
breast cancer and the drug Herceptin
which is approved for many many years so
if you would take all breast cancer
patients and fifteen percent is her2
positive if you would start to measure
her too and have Herceptin then after
some twenty patients our system would
indicate that two her2 positive ones are
the ones that are responding and then
the next patient who's her2-positive
would go into dead arm of the trial and
in that way we are enriching for the
patients who respond so we select the
high-risk patients by looking into the
biology using this 70 gene prognostic
signature and if that is high and then
those patients are randomized first of
all on biomarker signatures that use the
estrogen progesterone her too and the
mama print score in in another high-risk
one in high-risk two part so here is a
list of drugs new agents that were
testing in these newly diagnosed patient
population and you can see that
different targets are listed in the
middle column and the one in purple are
the one that we actually either
successfully graduated or one was
dropped for futility the ones that are
in white are currently in the trial in
seven agents are in the pipeline
actually that one if one comes out of
the trial in you and can come in
so this is all one trial process which
is not running for five years and when
every new drug only needs an amendment
to get into the trial so this is how it
works there is one standards arm
standard of care and they're up to five
experimental arms where the
investigational agent is given together
with standard of care patients are being
diagnosed so this is their first breast
cancer evaluated by imaging and a biopsy
is taken and then on going there are
imaging MRIs as well as biopsies or
blood draw and the endpoint is surgery
and this time frame is six months so
there's a much shorter time frame then
of course five years or ten years so we
recognize patients can be heard to
positive or negative and in each of
those their multiple arms we take the
MRIs and biopsies and every patient
informs actually the system and once we
reach a statistical significance and
I'll show you how we do that then the
drugs can go out of the trial in a new
one will come in so in a simplistic way
in the start of the trial the learning
part the patients are randomly assigned
to an arm we determine based on their
pretreatment biopsy their biology based
on just a few simple marker so far and
then we recognize eight different types
here indicated by purple blue and
yellowish and we then at time of surgery
the pathologist will determine whether
there's tumor cells left or not and if
there is no tumor cells left indicated
by an X this is called pathological
complete remission and actually
remarkably after three cycles of therapy
so that's really early on in the trial
so it's at this early this time point
already thirty percent of the patients
have no sign of tumor left so the sum of
these drugs are very efficient and even
after three cycles so this is a few
weeks you could you can already identify
who are the ones who will likely end up
without tumor at surgery so we're
actually evaluating that so that's in
future time we can start to change
therapeutics even early on eventually
recurrence you mean okay so these are
newly diagnosed patients so the tumor
remains in the breast and we're
following it for six months and so we're
looking at shrinkage of the tumor or not
and then their surgery so the tumor is
it's over there actually a few patients
when there is really after three cycles
no tumor left and there's no tumor on
their pre surgery MRI there are a few
patients who have opted to do no surgery
at all and some of our previous trial XE
are still disease free but it's like by
no way a standard of care so this is you
start to assign randomly and one at one
point you start to recognize that
biology type tool response to drug one
so you start to enrich for that
particular biological subtype in that
arm assess the pcr and when there is a
predicted likelihood of a success in a
subsequent 300 patient phase 3 trial
then the drug can graduate out of the
trial and we it's anticipated that you
only need a hundred two hundred twenty
patients to find a successful drug
biomarker combination or a failure and
actually our first graduation was after
even only seventy-two patients so you
have less patience a shorter time frame
and so you're set up to earlier
graduates drugs to a next phase and the
FDA actually recognized it for high-risk
breast cancer this is a very relevant
endpoint so they now allow partly based
on what we have built with I spy to that
that is a
valid approval status so we begin the
trial with equal randomization
probability calculate success for each
of the biomarker signatures then we
record for every patient that goes to
that we run again graduation or futility
and then if it's above a certain
threshold of the success in the next
trial then there is a stop of accrual in
that arm or if there are too many
patients it stopped because it will
never be better and then a new drug will
enter the trial so I'll show you just to
go dive a little bit deeper into the
biomarkers and genomics one of the first
arms which was a far inhibitor so that's
a DNA repair inhibitor seventy-two
patients were randomized to get these
drugs and sixty-two patients were
concurrently to the standard regimen so
those are the controls 44r her2-negative
and those are actually the ones that are
being evaluated against the drug so this
is the proportion of patients in each of
the her2 negative groups that were
treated that were her2-negative hormone
receptor positive or negative monoprint
high one or high too which is ultra high
yes we doin all come to this in a minute
that's actually a minority so we soap
this truck was given to all her2
negative patients and you can see in all
patients it does a little bit better
than the control if you look at yet the
triple negative group it does twice as
well as the control where is the other
group the one of these hormone
receptor-positive it doesn't really do
better so this is the signature for
which it was enriched and it shows high
probability of success in an X trial so
we identified the biomarker signature
based on just only hormone receptor and
her to that it does have to be negative
and but if you look at the data then
even in that group is only fifty two
percent who respond so it's still not
everybody so there's room for
improvement
so we have been we started to look in
what is actually the biology of those
patients that that are responding where
is in in parallel this particular
combination is now being tested in phase
3 for just a triple negative patient
group so that mean and the debts trial
concluded accrual so that means that
from the start we have now a four year
time frame a tube and I think they will
need another year follow-up so five
years until we would know whether this
drug combination can be accepted by the
FDA it's already pointed out there's 50
to respond so how about other biological
pathways and we're set up to actually
qualify biomarkers and there comes all
these DNA repair and breka status so
those are hypothesis testing various
that will which I will show you some of
the results whereas we're also going
into the exploratory phase where we're
just going to analyze all of our
next-generation sequencing
phosphoprotein data to even do better so
we have of all these patients so 1,700
have been screened almost 800 are up to
surgery a thousand went into the trial
so we have more than 30,000 biospecimen
files over these different time points
and are are their tumor biopsies or
plasma is here more buffy coat to test
and to look into all the biomarkers but
it means that one every patient has
three times that biopsy cores are taken
from the tumor which are like tiny tiny
course so there are a thousand my chrome
and we are able to actually section from
one all of these sections by microtome
frozen and we can do for most patients
all of these essays out of one of those
tiny course sometimes we need a second
one and we qualify those that they need
to have more than thirty percent tumor
cells so this
so we have a wealth of data starting to
accumulate to further tests so how about
these fifty two percent of patients who
responded to this part inhibitor the
parp inhibition works on the DNA repair
so if you further inhibit then you
assume that if you are doing it
efficiently and the tumor cell is indeed
dependent on this DNA repair deficiency
then you will be able to have the cancer
cell died and the patient will get a
pathological complete remission so we
tested either in the germline which is
number one the breca one and two status
which is of course the hallmark of
patients having a DNA repair deficiency
intrinsically and number two to five or
actually essays we did on the tumor
itself to see if we could find signs
signals for DNA repair deficiency either
by a gene expression profile we
developed for pop inhibition based on
selling data in the past or a brecon
asst signature for instance which can
identify DNA repair deficient cells and
we actually also used ultra high risk
signature so highly proliferating cells
so it's a very complicated scheme and I
can go into details later but we have a
three-step process where first we look
into the relative performance of such a
signature in the treated patients versus
to control so it needs to do better in
the treated patients and in the control
because then its associated if this is
passed then we evaluated in the context
of the in this case the triple negative
graduating signature if that passes then
we go to step 3 and we do an actual
beijing analysis as in the randomization
engine because it's an enrichment trial
you need to do ab Asian analysis to
actually be able to compare apples to
apples in this case so the association
with response
there is a threshold of a p-value of
lower than 0 point 0 5 and each of these
that have a yes past it and so you can
see that the break a mutation status
passed within the vc arm but not as a
interaction because they're actually too
few breca mutated patients in the whole
trial something could still valid
biomarker but our group was too small so
they that's just my status energy to do
in sequence bracket to wear this for
Samaritan this is germline mutation
testing which was performed by myriad
genetics you have somatic status we have
we are actually now also developing
mutations in the tumor tissue itself but
so far it was only germline so we looked
at this part inhibition and break in a
signature and you can see if you adjust
for subtype in this case triple negative
this part inhibition and the Brecon of
status is significant and in the
bayesian i realized i will show you many
different types of analyses so beijing
in this analysis gave you gives you a
probability of pathological complete
response so i showed you before the 52
versus the twenty six percent since
we're adding a few more markers in this
particular analysis of all triple
negative it is 56 first is 27 if you
then take the ones that are barp
inhibition signature hi you can increase
which is sixty-five percent of this
group you can increase this probability
to sixty nine percent if you take the
very high proliferating tumors you
increase it to 64 and if you combine it
you increase it to seventy-nine percent
so what we effectively have done is it
again back to this unselected group if
you take the forty percent of this group
that have both markers we can predict
eighty percent almost response rate
which is really really high where is the
other sixty percent there's hardly any
response
so we're actually pretty excited about
these results by like homing in on who
is what biology and having it like a
real stringent process I don't know
whether any of you have ever worked with
Tom Barry but to get something like this
and that takes light and be for him to
approve what to show take several weeks
but anyway I think we have a very
stringent process and I'm excited that
really the biology can help you to zoom
in and it's further detailed here the
estimated pcr rates here in numbers
again goes from 56 to 79 and the
probability of success in a phase 3
trial would still be 99 percent so this
particular one ended in all triple
negative is currently conducted by
Abbott who is the owner of this part
inhibition so we hopefully can test our
biomarker combination to see if we can
identify there again the ones that truly
respond so we screen in I spy two
patients with high risk more
proliferative tumors where this
pathologic complete response is
predictive for therapy response and
actually we know is also predicted for
long-term outcome in general this
accelerates the process of identifying
drugs that are effective in specific
breast cancer subtypes and that we
dramatically reduces costs time and
number of patients to get these drugs to
the markets because the FDA is given is
an accelerated approval status so we are
working with 10 4 different pharma
companies who all want to test their
drugs in this particular setting they
all run their own trials as well but
this is one of them one step further
into the genomics and computation which
we actually starting up right now is in
these exploratory biomarkers where this
is the integrated data systems that we
have so the whole ice by clinical trial
runs on a Salesforce system with all
these
different data types there's a lot of
molecular data that all sits either in a
specific system or also in hospital
systems like sequencing so we're
actually built were currently now
deposited the first data on the
supercomputer at San Diego and we're
working with the bd2k and global
alliance group to use api's to actually
efficiently interrogate this data but
actually building this integration layer
here I'm not the expert but I talked to
many people I think nobody really has
built this efficient integration layer
so you're constantly talking to
different people and I think the
challenge is to find a combination of
experts from different companies from
different academia to actually really
build this part efficiently so if you
have ideas and i'll be happy to talk to
you the last part is maybe also this
particular here on the bottom littered
in dilute too but as we are testing
biomarkers in a stringent way actually
that facilitates that we can do that
under a particular fda-approved system
which is called the IDE and
investigational device exemption for you
can test your biomarker as part of the
clinical trial and then would get
approval for many many years very active
in this particular part because it
requires very very robust genomics
assessment and validation as well as
normalization in every step and the real
word context is that even when you do
research you're sort of sitting here we
now are doing these clinical trials and
we're moving into the regulation and it
can give many many other talks how does
actually get into the clinical arena and
to convince CMS and pears and
professional organization that it's good
to actually use what we are all here
producing so thank you very much
don't work in you have several cases we
take multiple cores so it have any
pretty sufficiently good quality
material that you could actually a skate
at all and the profile salty a good
question so there so in principle yes
have we done it no so there's constant
challenge is to take these biopsies and
do such a study or to wait and use our
biopsies for yet another extreme Wells
like now we are like many people are
working on self recirculating DNA tests
so that actually which we are really in
favor of so we have plasma of all these
patients in many different but we need
them to do whole genome deep sequencing
on every core so we have interested
parties who actually want to do it with
us on every core so then we save that
core for that particular that particular
reason so there's all the time a
challenge what you want to do and now
with these the circle itself
recirculating DNA for instance that
requires four to six mil plasma and we
have four to six mil plasma because as I
told you we have like thirty thousand
files so we should have actually had a
little bit more plasma so my latest
proposal is that just one of these arms
will spend all the plasma on this cell
free DNA testing because that's what
they require but it sort of always a
trade-off so yes we could do it but we
haven't done it when it comes to
Ct DNA screening it really depends on
how deep you'd like to go yeah it's some
information to be gained even if you use
help it's irrelevant yeah because what
we actually alluded to that earlier we
actually very well set up soon so
originally drugs are tested and you need
in cancer to wait five or ten years
depending a little bit on the cancer
type but in breast cancer you need to
wait you used to need to wait five to
ten years because something got approved
with this pathological complete
remission is an endpoint it's a six
months time frame but actually we see on
our MRIs and in our biopsies that after
three cycles thirty percent of tumors a
certain percent of patients have no
tumor left so they should continue but
we also can model that some other forty
percent is very likely to not benefit so
why give these patients and other four
months of the drug where we already know
that they're not going to benefit you
would want to change and so I think also
circulating the in cell-free DNA will be
the detest to add there so we are
building our knowledge to get that type
point solidified you don't have all the
data yet but costs also a lot of money
what are you optimize it for sort of the
best outcome or learning more of the
experiment inter machinery is called an
expert so it so the the first layer of
that analysis is set to predict a
successful subsequent trial with 300
patients where you would give 150 the
drug 150 would get only standard of care
so that's what that's the level where
it's set now that we have edits are
qualifying biomarkers we're actually
setting it up to find the best
combination that gives the highest
probability of response so that's a
qualifying layer but not the graduating
layer of the drug so your question what
the FDA said you need to have two
subsequent trials that show the same
thing and then they will give the drug
accelerated approval so you talked about
selecting drugs based on stratification
of counts of sometimes what prevents us
from drinking every patient patient is a
single subtype and just finding the drug
it is the best characteristic window on
a cell culture derive from people have
done that actually so there have been a
number of companies that did that so you
could send a biopsy with living cells to
that company and they would test like 30
drugs or maybe 50 combinations and in
some cases it works but in many it
doesn't so that has never been proven to
be successful to predict response in the
patient in some cases yes but in many no
so if you ask me I think that what is
most needed is an inpatient imaging
marker response marker so that you early
on can see if somebody responds to a
drug like all the there I'm involved in
a large consortium that looks into
metastatic breast cancer metastatic
cancer patients so a lot of studies with
all of the large cancer centers across
the world seven are currently
participating to combine all their data
on uzhe its extensive targeted exome
sequencing with cancer type and drug
used so that leads in many cases to
off-label drug use like b-ref v600 which
is a frequent mutation in melanoma and
lung if there's like one patient who had
that mutation in breast cancer who is
metastatic who has had all sorts of
treatment so are you going to give that
breast cancer patient is melanoma drug
yes or no and in some cases it will work
in other it will not so you need to
combine all that
data to understand what what is the
context when it works and when it does
not and so the American Association of
cancer research is setting up a database
it will be accessible by researchers to
actually further research all that data
and to recognize patterns so currently
it's only the variant calls but I think
if everybody starts to become
comfortable and sharing the data because
that's a big deal I think they will only
also start to share all of their
underlying next generation sequencing
data so then I think you can come to
sort of understanding the algorithms
when to use some when is it efficient to
use something for one patient as you
propose but there are a lot of
toxicities with these drugs so people
are hesitant sometimes follow a more
recent question those xenografts
xenografts are also being used which
also works in some cases but I think
ultimately you tested in the patient so
that was also the vision of I spy to
that we need in a safe setting start to
test these drugs in patients also he
takes a while to grow yeah
they're all this 56 bicycle combination
yeah there's and there of course safety
as well as
so they are so the whole I spy two which
is a phase two trial scheme it actually
has a whole I spy phase one group of
clinics where the investigational drugs
are tested in combination with the
standard of care taxanes the FDA so far
has said that if each of those
individual component has been tested
with tech same for toxicity then it can
be used as a combination that I mean
that's an ongoing discussion probably
you should take the remainder of the
questions offline yeah thank you